this man it was the star of the film all
square we just saw a great clip of it
opens in theaters and on demand October
12th everybody also knows him as Doug
Stamper in house of cards good to see
you again Michael Kelley all right let's
jump in with both feet here cuz I know
you're a big Atlanta sports fan you are
here in Los Angeles California the day
before the divisional series between the
Braves and Los Angeles Dodgers and
you're leaving on a jet plane I am I
have I've been gone for you know I'm
doing Jack Ryan right now and I've been
gone in South America for two and a half
months and have not been near my family
I think if I told my wife for a couple
more days it might not go over so well
and I just miss him so much
of course you're a dad first and doing
press for this to impress her house of
cards it's just been a busy it's a live
which is great for you so how are you
keeping up with the Braves down in South
America
i MLB man I could actually stream the
games from there so it was great and
that and if I was at work the resale
receptions not so great so yeah I can
get text but you can't actually get the
app in a lot of places so my dad and my
brother night we constantly every game
we're texting back and forth so Jack
Ryan kidding okay you're doing this this
big huge TV show for Netflix right then
all's on my bad your den Netflix for
house of cards I can't keep up with your
streaming and so you're looking down and
you're finding out about the exploits of
Ozzie alby's Ronald Cooney jr. etcetera
at center just think I love this team so
much to its it's been such a fun you
know yeah this is the first time in five
years we've learned that division but
it's been so fun following the
minor-league team and and the major
league team just watching them get to
where they are today so you're locking
on what what's going on triple-a and
don't lie yeah yeah you know at least
like the yeah I'm pretty much familiar
with all the 30 prospects and have been
for five years very matter-of-fact no
how many people actually do know what
their top would you know Brockman your
Red Sox top 30
prospects no chance no chance I mean I'm
not gonna see their name off 30 but you
know Jean Anderson and Kyle right like
all these young kids he's especially the
arms that we have coming up I was
showing Bryan my manager on the flight
here for next year we have you could
feel two full rotations and then there
were still like three guys that's all
gonna be in contention for a top-five
next year so it's exciting exact
sighting time to me embrace yeah and and
the fries out there and on the warning
trace of fries I got it it looks like
you you could be a little speedy yeah I
was a runner and I'm like no if he gave
me enough of a jump if he's like all
that guys almost 50 you know he gives
you a head start and I think you like if
he looked at me as like oh good job
cuz I could take him it's funny because
that's basically all the Braves were
known for last year was the freeze
pretty much and now this year they are a
young team that nobody's talking about I
mean last night we saw Rockies Cubs I
mean today that's all everybody's
talking about is the Cubs lost two home
games and they're done and the Dodgers
have Kershaw and they've got Manny
Machado and I could go on and on hear
about how the Brewers are an underdog
team but and nobody's talking about your
Braves that's it and what a great way to
go into the playoffs right nobody's
talking about you nobody's considering
you and and like you went over talking
about before its house money yeah we
weren't supposed to be here until next
year we were supposed to win I think 73
games issues right 190 well it's
interesting talking as yourself Michael
Kelly here on the Rich Eisen show and
you know you being in Atlanta sports fan
as well we were talking about earlier
how Cubs fans all show up at that game
last night they're dressed ready to
celebrate and they see an absolute
disaster unfolded what's the worst thing
that you have been a spectator for that
you have seen with your own two eyeballs
that you are just like I can't believe I
was here for this and you saw in person
in a negative yes sir uh as a sports fan
we got important well good in person
like that I don't know about in person
but I mean obviously the the Yankees
World Series was was rough 96 the
wild-card game
when all the fans through the track the
infield fly rule remember that big fans
went crazy through all the trash in the
field it was just madness like that's a
you know anytime you have a wild-card
loss in front and just just to being a
wild card game you like terrible
terrible feeling but I can't think I
said what I've seen my own words were
you at any that weird Super Bowl have
you been to a soup no thank God I was
not at that Super Bowl because I almost
went to Superboy would have been
watching the Falcons lose out of the
Patriots I can't imagine if I had to
watch that in in person I would have
walked home I mean I remember walking
from the bar I went to see it with my
friend Greg is a Patriots fan and we oh
my god it was act out we both walked
back to our neighborhood from the bar
and it was how do you walk back I was
just like I can't believe this believe
it now he was very cool and you know arm
on the shoulder kind of buddy man like
I'm I'm sorry
Sacha's Greg his buddy Greg doing one
solid for the New England sports
community that might not have been
settled thoughtful yeah yeah sir how
people it was yeah a good friend right
there yeah he's a good guy okay good all
right so let's talk about your your film
all square here you kind of play a
Buttermaker character from back in the
day of Bad News Bears
guy who's a little bit rough around the
edges you play a bookie for friending a
young boy teaching them life lessons
while also trying to make book and kind
of I guess bring everybody together yeah
through all square is that an
appropriate yeah yeah yeah you know it's
the kind of guy who is trying to teach
life lessons thinking that he's doing
the right thing sort of like you know
Billy Bob Thornton's character in Bad
Santa he's giving advice like like he's
a genius and he's not quite a genius
mm-hmm but he's got a good heart and and
and the film has a good heart like it's
got a you know it's not this you don't
get the super happy ending but everyone
gets a little bit better in the film
like everyone grows like an inch and
then like the Bad News Bears it's
of this you know tip your hat so to
speak to that to that genre to that
old-school style of filmmaking where
it's just a little slice of life and it
doesn't have to be you know mm-hmm a big
blockbuster and it doesn't have to be
this super happy ending it's just this
is a cool little film and it's even kind
of has that look to it as you saw in the
in the trailer
well you you also told me there's a
little wink and a nod to the Bad News
Bears at yes correct Chico's Bail Bonds
we have in the outfield there at the
park there you one of our banners in the
outfield is Chico's there's a couple
things in there that I think real sports
fans are gonna get a kick excellent and
it's in theaters on demand 12th and
house of cards returns November 2nd yeah
okay for the final now you for those who
are watching right now and can hear as
well you are a very nice person
thank you smiling a lot laughing a lot
Doug Stamper who you play on house of
cards is exactly the opposite yeah where
do you find that I always say that
there's you know that there's a little
bit of you and every one that you play
you try to bring as much of yourself to
the character I just I don't know where
I am in that guy except for that he does
I believe at least I mean I know that he
does some horrible things but he does
have a good heart underneath he does
what he does because he thinks it's the
right thing to do mm-hmm but inside he's
you know he's a misunderstood kind of
guy he's a complicated listeners that
kind of guy right it has a decent Hardy
just never has had you know you see the
relationship with his brother with his
family it's never nothing was ever great
in his life you know so he's just sort
of finding his way through it and and
his addiction is work his mm-hmm all
that is sort of a byproduct he just
finds his way through life well I'm not
gonna troll for a spoiler because I know
you will not Koff one up yeah but can
you leave does it does it get tied up in
a neat bow by the end of it I mean this
give us that certainly certainly a lot
I mean they do it is a proper ending in
a send-off to a show that it's been on
for four six years you know you do I
think the audience will feel some sense
of resolve to it it's it's I'm such a I
can't believe what the writers pulled
off you know when you think about the
fact that we were two episodes in with
Kevin mmm when when they put us on the
hole there and what they were able to
pull off in three months come Edie all
thirteen were pretty much done and then
to completely rewrite a season in three
months so that's what that's well I I do
remember that you were two episodes in
when Kevin Spacey had known was pulled
off the cast yeah it they so you as an
actor and everybody else you go back to
whatever you were doing or whatever you
had to do
yeah three months while the the writers
came yeah I mean what rewrote the final
season yeah of house of cards yeah and
it happened in stages right we all went
home I was home when it happened
happened midday and Robin was there and
cheap said let's finish the day and the
whole crew stayed they were like you
guys can go home and they were like
let's finish our day and they all stayed
and finished the day and then we were on
on a on a hiatus and there was a lot of
uncertainty but Robin and myself and you
know Netflix and MRC everyone was just
like we got a we got to finish this and
it was just sort of like okay but how
you know so there was three months of
sort of figuring out how we could do it
and how we could bring that conclusion
for the fans and and you know that was
the first streaming show on Netflix it
was the first original content show and
I think everyone's just say well we
gotta finish it we have to so i cuz i
was gonna say that
michael kelly here and the richardson
show that you know the ultimate
compliment to house of cards is when you
first came on the air it's like okay
interesting show but it's on a streaming
service you know like it's not on TV and
it's not on pay cable and it's not
something that i could just turn the
television on I got to find it on my TV
or stream it now there's thousands
thousands yeah shows hey you know it's
funny I remember having the phone call
with with be my manager and we were
he was like how's it going we were a few
weeks in and ventured showed me some
some dailies David Fincher David Fincher
sorry editor and and he said how's it
going and I was like we're making
something incredible I don't know if
anyone's ever gonna see it something
incredible you know I I knew you could
feel it on set the writing was so good
the directing was so good the acting was
was incredible I had never been
surrounded by mmm such a group of fine
actors at that time in my career and it
was just we all knew it mm-hmm but it
was the unknown was Netflix funny enough
I mean how are they gonna watch it right
you know and and now it's just second
nature and your honor in an Amazon show
Jack Ryan with John Krasinski who is a
die-hard Patriot fan yes um because
funny you were on my podcast with my
wife yesterday and she's a die-hard
Patriot fan and she was making fun of my
jet fandom without revealing her Patriot
fandom yet and I might guess what teams
years and you what don't tell me which
she was gloating I was like that's a
Patriots fan we're gonna win we always
win it's crazy like that too
no he's a pretty cool guy I mean he he
laughs he laughs about that but windle's
actually worse because he's a Saints fan
we've had him on the show and he is but
he told me something we were just
together - birthday party a few nights
ago and he said you know what I'm I'm
gonna stop [ __ ] talking because he I've
decided
because he was like he was he was
jabbing me about the upcoming game and I
was like I don't do that man I got it I
don't talk trash because it just always
comes back to bite you and he's like
what do you mean he didn't understand I
don't know man
good luck you know so what do you say
after the game he he was he was pretty
cool lucky he throws one around and then
and then he's like you know I'm just
playing but then he told music I think
I'm gonna stop doing that one in three
your Falcons unfortunately but it does
you got the Braves to be diving
headfirst into for the playoffs
all square in theaters and on demonic
Tober 12th viewer good man Michael Kelly
that's the luck with everything you're
doing with the house of cards can't wait
to see the finale and Jack Ryan on
Amazon and all square and everything
else that you're up to thanks man you
got always a pleasure Michael J Kelly JR
jr. on Twitter I follow him you should
as well or back with more in a moment
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience